allies across the board are stepping up
increasing defense spending
a majority of them are on track for the
first time to exceed our two percent of
gdp commitment that they make they agree
to spend two percent of the gdp on
defense
look
for example germany
germany has committed to spending two
percent going forward and announced
a special fund for its military of more
than 100 billion dollars
slovakia the czech republic and the
netherlands have announced they will
also meet their 2 commitments
poland romania estonia latvia lithuania
are doing more than 2.5 percent some as
high as 3 percent
together deploying more assets and
capabilities to bolster our alliances
across all domains
land air sea cyber and space
we've reaffirmed that our article 5
commitment is sacred
and an attack on one as an attack on all
and we will defend every inch of nato
territory every inch of nato territory
for our part the united states is doing
exactly what i said we would do if putin
invaded
enhance our force posture in europe
we'll station more ships than here in
spain
we're stationing more air defense in
italy and germany more f-35s in the
united kingdom
and to strengthen our eastern flank new
permanent headquarters for the army
fifth corps in poland
in addition an additional brigade combat
team positioned in romania
and additional
rotational deployments in the baltic
countries
things are changing to adapt to the
world as we have it today
and all this is against the backdrop of
our response to nato's to russia's
aggression and to help ukraine defend
itself
the united states is rallying the world
to stand with ukraine
allies and partners around the globe are
making significant contributions
secretary austin
just brought together more than 50
countries more than 50 countries
pledging new commitments
and this is a global effort to support
ukraine
nearly 140 000 anti-tank systems more
than 600 tanks
nearly 500 artillery systems more than
600 000 rounds of artillery ammunition
as well as advanced multiple launch
rocket systems anti-ship systems and air
defense systems and again
the united states is leading the way
we provided ukraine with nearly 7
billion in security assistance since i
took office
the next few days we intend to announce
more than 800 million more including new
advanced western air defense systems for
ukraine more artillery and ammunition
counter battery radars additional
ammunition for the highmars multiple
launch rocket system we've already given
ukraine and more highmars coming from
other countries as well
we're also welcome for the first time
our partners in indo-pacific to
participate in the nato summit
as i indicated to putin this would be
his action would cause worldwide
response
bringing together democratic allies and
partners from the atlantic and the
pacific
to focus on the challenges that matter
to our future
and to defend the rules-based order
against the challenges
including from china